Saturday Night Live return this weekend
with a Bittersweet tribute to the late
Canadian icon Norm McDonald with Pete
Davidson rocking a t-shirt with Norm's
face on it I love it it's the best and
later The Weekend Update hosts Colin
Jost and Michael Shea shared a special
tribute to Norm with the Highlight Reel
of his best jokes
well guys it is a Bittersweet night for
us tonight yeah on September 14th our
friend Norm Macdonald passed away that's
right um Norm is the reason that I ever
wanted to do Weekend Update and so
tonight we thought we'd turn the last
few jokes of update over to Norm
thanks I'm Norm Macdonald and this is
the fake news
at the White House this week President
Clinton officially came out against
same-sex marriages what's more the
president said he is not too crazy about
opposite sex marriages either
a new airport planned for San Diego
would actually be located three miles
out in the Pacific Ocean built on 40 by
20 foot floating cylinders it's all part
of a plan by City officials to have a
huge disaster
a French man who calls himself the snake
man was arrested this week after
climbing up the side of a Manhattan
high-rise yep he climbed right up the
side of a high-rise just like a snake
in a brilliant move during closing
arguments Simpson attorney Johnny
Cochran put on the knit cap prosecutors
say O.J War the night he committed the
murders although OJ may have heard his
case when he suddenly blurted out hey
easy with that that's my lucky stabbing
hat
[Applause]
good night and good luck